Speaker 1: We knew it would eventually
happen. And a Fox News host is now
blaming cannabis for mass shootings and
specifically for the shooting last week in Texas.
Why wouldn't they eventually get the cannabis?
They've blamed everything else other than guns.
They blamed COVID masks. They blamed video games.
They blamed doors. They blamed mental illness.
They blamed COVID lockdowns and the isolation
that comes from it. They blamed Wokeness. They
blamed I know I'm forgetting some things, but
it makes sense that they would eventually get
the cannabis and that's now what they are talking
about. So let's look at this clip of Fox News host
Laura Ingraham and look at the effort she goes
through in order to point the finger at cannabis
here. And we're going to talk about it. This
is from last night's show. There's a lot here.
So we'll do our best to keep up with all of it.
Speaker 5: And speaking of drugs, according to
The Daily Mail, well, The New York Times had
originally reported that Ramos smoked pot.
Then mysteriously, the reference was
missing from the online editions.
Now. Why is that? Hmm. Was it bad information
or is this the pro-marijuana bias that we've
become accustomed to? That's so powerful because
billions are on the line with it nationwide.
So this a story now irrelevant. We reached out to
the Times on this, but they have not responded.
Speaker 1: Now, when we're going to keep
going with this, when it comes specifically
to the Texas shooter, one of the
important questions would be, okay,
we can talk about cannabis, but if you're going
to make a claim about cannabis, are you arguing
that the cannabis made him go and buy the guns?
Like, was he high and decided to go buy the guns
because he was high? Or are you saying that
the guns were purchased with a clear mind,
but then smoking pot made him say, Well,
now I'm going to go and do a shooting?
Was the high all the time or like one of
the issues when people do this stuff that
Laura Ingram's doing is what is even the claim
that you're making? Let's see if she makes one.
Speaker 5: Now, the American people are hearing
a lot about AR 15 and background checks,
but they also deserve to hear about this as well.
Respected medical studies for years now have
demonstrated that pot use, especially among teens,
can trigger psychosis and increase the chance that
a young person will develop violent behaviors.
Speaker 1: Now, let's say that that's true,
and we're going to get eventually to the
science on all of this. If that were true.
It would be great. Like, let's say you're Laura
Ingram. Okay, I'm buying into what she says.
If that's true, it would be great to have the
opportunity to know, hey, this person smokes pot.
We shouldn't let them buy guns. Well, how
would you do that? One way would be to have
an initial and periodic mental health evaluation
and during which people are asked about drug use
and requiring for people under age 25 who want
to buy firearms, requiring letters of sort of
recommendation, as it were, from adults in the
community. And it would give you an opportunity to
find out if this is someone who smokes pot. Now,
I'm not even saying if you smoke pot, you should
or shouldn't be able to get a gun. I'm merely
saying, if her concern is that people who smoke
pot not be allowed to have guns, then why not
put in some of the systems I mentioned last week
to allow us to figure that out? Well, but she's
against that. So even this is not something they
are genuinely committed to. But let's continue.
Speaker 5: The Association of Mature American
Citizens. Right. A 2017 study identified
marijuana as the single most common correlative
variable in otherwise diverse populations
and circumstances surrounding the Association
of Violence and Marijuana.
Speaker 1: Now, choral correlative
is an important word because as we know,
correlations and causation are two different
things, but we'll get back to that.
Speaker 5: Reported links exist to
shooters in Parkland, El Paso, Dayton,
Aurora, Colorado. Tucson, Chattanooga,
Sacramento and perhaps elsewhere. Now, a friend of
the Dayton shooter, Connor Betts, told authorities
that he was a gun owner and that he had
done hard drugs with Betts, as well as
marijuana and acid. Four or five times a week.
Speaker 1: Now, that's essentially meaningless
in drawing, drawing causation, hard drugs and
marijuana and acid. Well, it's kind of hard to
blame the marijuana in that case, isn't it?
Speaker 5: From 2014 to 2015,
former New York Times reporter Alex
Berenson has written extensively OC.
Speaker 1: Alex Berenson is a joke,
and so I'm going to pause this here.
So this is actually really tricky because there
are actually two questions. The first question is
physiologically, does using cannabis make people
or more people more violent either while they are
under the influence or in a future moment, even
when not actively under the influence? So there's
the physiological question separately. There's the
question of is obtaining cannabis associated with
violence? And what I mean by that is one issue
could be the physical interaction of cannabis,
THC or CBD with the body. Does that cause someone
to become violent? But another would be because
the cannabis market is still a black market in
many places for recreational cannabis. Does being
around a black market of drug dealing put you near
violent situations? That's that's another question
which you would really have to take seriously.
These are dramatically different questions. Now,
I'm giving Laura Ingram too much credit because
I'm pretending she's like an honestly talking
about this, which obviously she's not. Ingram
cites a piece by the Association of Mature
American Citizens. That's just a right wing lobby.
It doesn't they don't do it. It's just an advocacy
group that's a right wing group. We have good
studies on the link between cannabis and violence,
and it is true that a number of studies have found
a slight correlation between violent behavior
among cannabis users. That's absolutely true.
There's I mean, it's just what it is. I have
no interest in denying that they have not been
able to establish any causality at this point.
And additionally, it hasn't been established that
cannabis makes people not predisposed to violence
any more violent. And that's a critical thing.
Lastly, there is no evidence I was able to find
that cannabis use makes people
more likely to commit crimes.
We could imagine a scenario where one's
threshold for aggressive behavior might be
lowered by cannabis, hypothetically. But that
doesn't mean that it's going to take someone
not predisposed or interested in committing
crimes and make them go and commit crimes
because they're high. But of course, it's the
typical double standard because the correlation
between alcohol and crime is off the charts. The
correlation between alcohol and domestic violence
is completely off the charts compared to cannabis.
It's a widely established link and Fox never talks
about it because it's not convenient. Laura did
a bunch on this yesterday. She then brought on
some guy. Let's see if we can figure out
who this guy is. Saying, why are people,
more and more people talking about this pot thing?
Speaker 5: It was initially reported that he was a
user. In fact, he got angry that his grandmother,
his mother, didn't want him to use marijuana.
But again, we don't know more. It was
just mysteriously taken out of an article
in The New York Times. But why are people in
general not talking more about the pot psychosis,
violent behavior, connection?
Speaker 2: Well, that's a very good question.
Speaker 1: Okay. But last thought on this. Explain
this to me. It's not the guns, it's the people.
So there's no sense in banning any guns.
But it is the drugs, not the people.
And so we should ban drugs. I mean, that doesn't
seem to make too much sense to me either. Science
aside, so there's Laura Ingram with her new
shiny toy. And that shiny toy is cannabis